the Joe Rogan experience apparently a
lot of people commit suicide after being
on reality shows but you don't really
sort of hear about it just because you
get so famous and then nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you and you drop money yeah
and your money yeah that's pretty well
to have that kind of Fame and out of
nowhere and did not really know why you
have it then have it taken away from you
and then to not have any money I mean
think about yeah the kind of a
psychological test apparently have to
take to be on a reality show are pretty
hardcore mmm not in the fear factor days
oh really
I bet they were just talk to people how
are you doing it's me they're like
wherever they were background checks and
[ __ ] though right Oh a few we clearly
had some insane people on that show why
are they getting paid fifty thousand
dollars if they won sometimes it was
more like it was a big episode like they
would win a million we had one guy won a
million dollars started speaking in
tongues I'm at how about he was like
super religious and he was gonna give
all the money to like he was gonna tithe
10% of his money I was like $100,000 and
he was uh that was one of the rare ones
where they went a million but most of
the most 50,000 did you get to have say
and the stuff that they did no no say
and I most of the time didn't know I
didn't know until I got there that's
[ __ ] crazy yeah part of it was me I
didn't want to know because part of it
was because part of is because I thought
it would be better if it was a surprise
to me so the day of I could be kind of
more enthusiastic about it because it
was so crazy man because some of the
stunts were so [ __ ] crazy but there
was a few times where I told him to stop
I told him don't do this what the
contestants and producers everybody I
said let's not do this one don't do it
and they were like you're crazy I'm like
why we had people ride bulls and that
was the first one I was like you guys
are out of your [ __ ] mind like this
is so dangerous
Roman games at this point well you're
they had a 98 year old a 90 pound 98
pound girl she was 98 pounds she was so
tiny and they made her ride the ball and
she went flying through the air just got
so lucky that the bull didn't kick her
in the face and I'm telling you it
dup and her head was here and the foot
went like this just right by her is that
even legal links legal you sign off on
the waiver people ride bulls take a
chance I mean that's exactly what
happened and I was telling people don't
do this and I told the producers uh I
said don't do this look I've had a
healthy fear of animals my whole life I
was attacked by a goat when I was like
seven years old it was Hitler really
yeah
Hitler lost a testicle to a goat goat in
my is that he's got a myth it sounds as
like a myth as I said it I remember him
I think a goat bit what is nothing
I was I was butted by a goat and my
stepfather had to come and save me I
like a like a petting zoo now is that a
farm co-op when we lived in San
Francisco there was uh my stepdad went
back to school and he was a who's
originally a computer programmer and
then he was going back to school to be
an architect and one of the things that
he did it was part of his university was
they had some sort of some sort of a
farming co-op thing we had to take care
of like certain like farming chores and
there was animals like like goats mm-hmm
and I was a little kid and then got left
in this [ __ ] room with this goat this
pen was gone I'm sorry I'm laughs at the
beginning and then the goat [ __ ] just
came at me and slammed his chest yeah oh
yeah they're no joke and I remember I'm
grabbing the horns but I didn't have any
strength I was a little kid you know I
was maybe eight at the time and he had
to come and save me and I was like Jesus
Christ and I remember thinking from that
time I like oh you gotta get this idea
of what an animal is out of your head
like they didn't that thing didn't give
a [ __ ] if I died this is we just stomped
me to death it would have been fine this
is it was I'm right about that
there's that that could be a total
googled Hitler's not Hitler
goat now government so do you know there
are two things about algorithms gonna
doesn't have anything to do with it I
guess
he had undescended testicle apparently
and then he also had something called
hypo spade yes hmm something to do with
the urethra hole being on the under
of the penis and not where it should be
or had a [ __ ] up penis course he did
that's why I'm so angry I makes so much
sense what did he not have any goat
accident I typed encoded this it's a rap
what it's like I need to figure out
where that [ __ ] came from but there's
so many it this says it was a bit by a
goat his younger days but it's okay my
goat is balls I was attached to his man
I think every kid was bit by goat at
some point man
[Applause]